hey everyone steve weintraub with
collider i am thrilled to be with the
cast of dungeons and dragons uh i
legitimately like no bs i am really
excited for your movie i think that
trailer looks great and it looks the one
word i would use is fun
it just looks really fun how have you
actually been describing what what do
you want to tell fans about the movie in
terms of like the tone what you're
excited for them to see i've always
described it as like princess bride
meets monty python meets the the size
and scope of game of thrones um
it has uh
without the sex
with lusty earnest uh virgin hearts
um
it it it has that i i mean it's like my
favorite kind of sensibility that 80s
pop sensibility that's fun and and light
and kinetic and
um
uh that has a lot of levity obviously
but really great heart and great
earnestness and it's not cynical and
it's not meta and it's not any of that
it's just good old-fashioned fun
storytelling hugh if i'm not mistaken
you could be the antagonist in this
movie it's complicated steve i've
i seem that way but i think i'm more
complicated than that i think there are
people worse than me
in this film as i recall i can barely
remember it we filmed it a year ago but
uh i think that's that's right but i'm
certainly fascinating
are you guys agreeing with his
assessment or would you say he's more of
the antagonist i'd say it's fairly quite
accurate
yeah
incredibly accurate yeah
and tago narcissist yeah
one of the things that a dungeons and
dragons movie has is what's called
dragons and we obviously see some of
that in the footage uh at the pre that
the big thing the paramount built here i
thought i saw a black dragon and i think
there was another dragon i saw in the
footage so let me ask you are there a
lot of dragons in the movie or are we
talking like one dragon i think we can
confirm multiple dragons
yeah
yeah
multiple dragons that sounds about right
so you guys filmed this i believe in
iceland and in belfast were all am i
wrong about this no i i they're major
iceland plates but it was all foamed um
in belfast okay so the ice okay so then
i got it so i let me ask you this uh
filming in in belfast uh what was it
like being there what did it add filming
in that see the movie belfast
it was nothing like that
and this is what it was like
um
so you're saying they're great locations
i mean northern ireland is beautiful i
mean there are some places and also we
went to some spots in england did we not
yeah that were quite extraordinary you
want to talk about that sofia
you're just dying to get on the mic
aren't you yeah absolutely
uh no northern ireland was fantastic we
shot at the the titanic stages which
uh
interesting history we may as well just
shot in a sardine can or just put up a
canvas tent and shot underneath that it
was the loudest
excuse for soundstage i've ever
shot in my entire life um they had coal
it was unbelievable but uh that aside
the the um
i mean you can't beat the the
countryside and uh what it afforded us
in terms of um
just the scenery was absolutely out of
control the northmen i think it just
shot there just wrapped so we ended up
using some of their
uh some of the stuff that they built and
we refurbished it as uh
as our own um
and then in turn the other interesting
thing that i mean i really liked about
it is that so much of the
as john and uh jonathan will talk about
it so much of the
effects work was practical so all that
stuff that you saw today in the teaser
little bit about the dying guys come you
know waking up none of it was cg it was
all these practical awesome
creations that were you know coming
alive before us as actors on the day
which was great fun one of the things i
love about john and jonathan's work is
that they really find great places to
add levity to scenes they're very very
funny people can you sort of talk about
working with them and the way they were
able to add like 11 making jokes even
though it's a dungeons and dragons movie
yeah i think the important part i'm just
saying please anyone [ __ ] answer
anyone
i will happily stop talking
you
well i tell you that was a big draw for
me
when this thing came my way i thought i
don't think i do that kind of film and
then i read it and it was so funny
brilliantly funny you're absolutely
right these guys seem to be sort of
raised on monty python or something and
uh that was that was a huge attraction
for me and i
i haven't seen the film but i think it
survived production jokes don't always
survive production but i think in this
case they have the the clip that was
played in the hall just now of the
the dead people
people loved it
i heard real laughs
that was actually paramount paying the
audience five bucks each to make to make
you feel good i'm i'm choking obviously
i'm being an [ __ ] um
but one of the things i saw the like the
in the footage you can see it the
costumes and the attention to detail do
you think that like a movie like this is
um
maybe
like a little it's like right on time
after the world sort of knows game of
thrones and the popularity of like
dungeons and dragons in the last you
know decade or two coming back a lot of
people playing like do you think it's
the right time you know for this to hit
from what i heard i forget who gave me
this number but there were like
two billion hours of dungeons and drag
dragons watched over multiple platforms
like youtube players playing dungeon
maybe apocryphal suffice it to say that
it's way more popular than i ever
imagined and when you get a bunch of
people together and you survey
you know 10 people more more often than
not the majority will have played or do
play dungeons and dragons in some sort
and you just haven't heard about it so i
think um
i i think it will appeal to obviously
players but again like any film
that has a rabid following i mean i know
that from star trek or whatever you have
to make it appealing to non-fans to
invite them into the fold and at the end
of the day this is just good
old-fashioned storytelling it's not
reinventing the wheel and and what we're
saying it's all about family and purpose
and identity and
uh
the hero journey and all the stuff that
stories are all about
um
but it does it i think really well in in
a in a
self-knowing way that doesn't slip into
meta or
farce or um too cool for school or
cynical it's just
poppy good entertainment i think with a
great message i'm gonna ask some
individual questions can you tell me i'm
all looking right at you
so let's look like
right let's talk about i believe your
character is an owl bear or am i wrong
about did i get that wrong you're kind
of right um
my i play a uh tiefling druid so i turn
into
various animals one of them
uh that is
true eat true yeah i forgot about that
small tidbit um
i don't know how to
react to that i'm here to help you thank
you um but yes no i am a tiefling druid
so um
uh throughout this story i turn into
various creatures i wanted to ask you
guys in the footage that i saw you both
look like you're badasses um and i'm
just curious what can you tease about
your characters and how much action you
actually get to do in the film i mean
chief badass he's two for sure uh he
says that but like five pounds of muscle
the whole time everyone's looking at him
like he's jesus
like he's just this hardcore like knight
and shining armor that just comes in and
i mean i don't think that his character
took it too well when he came along but
that's just me personally just like what
holga got out of it i don't know but
like yeah i think you were pretty bad we
did we did a we did a fair bit of
fighting we got to live out the whole
swinging sword swinging axes slaying
dragons to ping the bad guys type at all
but she was fascinated for some reason i
don't know maybe she saw like his prior
tv shows or something
what was her character to say she's a
big fan
just saying you know
hugh how were your action scenes
i was asked to turn them down
you know
too feasible just too much of a presence
on screen right
i bring a natural menace to cinema i
actually have one last thing
how much you guys were in hall age which
is the 7000 seat room and i saw online
people talking about what you guys were
saying how much were you thinking about
before you get on stage 7 000 seats yeah
it's like a ton of people holy shiza
yeah so my question is before you step
on stage for something like that are you
thinking about what am i gonna say are
you thinking about anything are you sort
of like [ __ ] it let's just go i was
horrified to watch
chris and michelle's entrances
he's doing boxing and uh god knows what
she comes on the
acrobatics
i thought i can't do that i'm 61. i'm
english i'm in quite a bad mood
[Laughter]
that was terrifying
yeah but i think you did the right thing
i mean i think you struck the right note
i think no for sure i i thought about it
quite a bit i think it comes naturally
if you've chosen
the film for a good reason i mean if you
have if you went into it with an intent
um
and thankfully the
i mean what i said on stage i really do
believe
playing the game that i had no interest
in at all
i was one of the [ __ ] that thought
it was just for dorks
and then i played it with my family
in the immediate joy that it created
with in my family the immediate bonding
within 20 minutes that it created
i was
completely taken with it and really
moved by
the unifying power of this game which is
essentially what acting i mean it is it
calls to mind everything that we're
asked to do as actors it's like you're
you know you're whatever you are you
have special powers x you're with these
people now make a family and go do
something
dude go do a story
and so it requires all the powers that
you have as an actor
and um
and it's completely unified because it's
it's it's
you can't say no it's all yes and yes
and yes and okay fine and this thing
happens okay how are we gonna get
through that so i was really quite blown
away by it so um
and really that uh what i said on stage
and
i think what makes this particular brand
um so special is that it has that
unifying power that especially in a
world now that we have that is just
nothing but you know disunity and chaos
it's nice to be reminded that
you know every once in a while playing
pretend and using your imagination for
something
fun and
you know
is good and is a force for good put that
to music there are the bad superpowers
right there
oh my god you still are doing that
on that note i really want to say thank
you guys to come for coming in dungeons
and dragons is going to be in theaters
in march of next year
thank you so much cannot wait to see the
movie thanks dude appreciate it thank
you appreciate it
you